president drum threatening to move this
summer's Republican National Convention
from Charlotte North Carolina to
who-knows-where unless Democratic
governor Roy Cooper immediately says
whether he will allow attendees to
completely fill the arena the president
tweeting quote if not we will be
reluctantly forced to find with all the
jobs and economic development it brings
another Republican National Convention
site this is not something I want to do
governor Cooper says data and science
will guide his decision on whether the
state can hold large gatherings like the
convention that is supposed to take
place toward the end of August
dr. staff I want to start with you let's
run a hypothetical let's pretend that
you are the medical adviser to the
Republican National Committee what would
you tell them
bottom-line it medically about having
potentially 50,000 attendees for the
convention in August what do you say
well Kennedy i mean it's extremely
complicated we're talking about several
months from now but I'll tell you
yesterday North Carolina just reported
their highest single day increase to
date so therefore you know they're still
seeing rising cases and you know if
they're following that White House
blueprint that was put forth by the
experts then they're not ready to say
that they're gonna be able to
accommodate 50,000 people and indoor
settings come end of August that being
said we're still several months away
from that so are there are there ways to
smartly do things so that they can have
it there absolutely but they have to
they have to be creative we can't just
go back to the business of usual we're
gonna pack everyone in like a herd of
cows and then potentially be
transmitting this because then you have
schools starting if they have this
massive rise of cases just at the end of
August then all of a sudden the Falls
school year is going to be completely
disrupted and if our goal is to try and
get children back to school that's not
smart but moving it somewhere else isn't
necessarily the right answer either so
let's just get put our minds together
and come up with some ways on how we can
do this have a lot more outdoor events
if you're gonna be inside maybe people
do need to be wearing face masks you
know maybe there will be increased
testing I mean I'm not sure there's
going to be a there are a lot of
variables there are smart ways to do
this to decrease the risk of
transmission
but the bottom line is putting a lot of
people in a small area is definitely not
good for us right now is looking out for
our long-term goal with kovat 19 you're
right so much is shifting and the
timeline keep shifting so it seems like
we're close to opening and you know the
end of August seems like it's really far
away but they got to make some of these
decisions so Joey let's say you are
advising the president and the RNC if
not North Carolina then where it's got
to be a swing state well and I think
that's the problem this is a political
thing that's getting in the way of a
medical and scientific thing right I am
a bit confused that president Trump's
manner towards this because of what the
doctor said it kind of contradicts or at
least goes up against the White House's
own rules and kind of guidelines but
with that being said politics takes all
especially in an election year that's
just the truth of the world we live in
you know they're pretty they're pretty
cozy with my governor governor Kemp I
know that Arthur Blank would probably
open up mercedes-benz stadium
responsibly for something like this or
perhaps they go down to Florida
president's new home state they seem to
be doing very well with the virus I
think it makes sense to go to a state
that's out there trending down or going
way down Texas might be that state it's
not a it's not a swing state or a place
to gain a lot of ground with the
convention I think it makes a lot of
sense to go somewhere with the numbers
favor large crowds or the risk of large
crowds and I think that would be
consistent with every table I don't see
cases having increase in cases North
Carolina is really only North Carolina
this week is only beginning its second
phase of reopening some restaurants some
hair salons very limited there is no
accommodation for something where 50,000
people could come together and socially
distance right now all right well it
we're writing the rules in the moment
and so much is going to change we don't
know where it's gonna end up solutely it
makes it exciting but incredibly
unpredictable